the problem is the liberal world order
is not working out very well and people
are seeing this in their pocketbooks
they're seeing this at the tank right
now they're seeing this at the gas
prices and most especially they're
seeing this with their own two eyes
in education in
regular old society and and specifically
with regard to children
we are told that the libs are not
groomers the the we've just come to the
end of pride parade we've made it
through we made it through guys a little
worse off than we were when we started
but we made it through
there was a video of a little kid
sweet little kid how old is he probably
four years old or something at a pride
parade looking at some
person
jiggling in an extremely sexual way not
wearing a lot of clothing
these kids staring up
and then some just
just absolute degenerate
dancing and twerking and jiggling around
while this kid looks up i don't know
where this might have been new york
looks sort of like new york i'm not not
quite sure exactly what the street is
no they're not sexualizing the kids no
no they're ju they're just offering
educational opportunities it's not
grooming it's not sexual oh that giant
lady or man or i don't know twerking and
jiggling right in the kid's face no
that's nothing there's another video
came out of what looks like a strip club
of a stripper we blared it out i don't
know if it's
a man or a woman or it's a man who
mutilated himself to look like a woman
whoever the person is definitely
has had some work done
walking around holding a little kid by
the hand dancing and stripping
[Music]
and this this dancer has sort of pasties
on so it's
maybe it's
maybe they're skirting some of the laws
here but but it's obviously extremely
indecent it's obviously obscene and and
this dancer is holding the little kid's
hand the most scandalous part of the
video by the way is not that this
dancer prostitute whatever this person
is it's not even that that person is
holding the kid's hand it's all the
adults who are just sitting there kind
of laughing chuckling
yeah
yeah free expression
yeah this is this is pride let's
celebrate let's celebrate pride
more and more of these videos come out
how many of these videos have i played
on my show
100
i don't know how many of these videos
come out how many of these videos do we
need to see before we realize
that this is a feature not a bug
of pride ideology
of leftist ideology
the
increasing sexualization of little
little little kids i'm not even talking
about
young teenagers
or
fifth grade or sixth grade i'm talking
that girl looks like she's four or five
if that
the increasing sexualization of ever
younger children
is a feature
not a bug
of this leftist ideology they've been
talking about it for 100 years at least
and now they're doing it and we're all
surprised that they're doing it
they're doing it because this is the
leftist vision of liberty on that tick
tock video they say kids should be
exposed to drag shows this is free
expression man we've gotta accustom them
to this when they're very very young
because the leftist vision of liberty is
that we're all oppressed by society by
the moral order by rules by discipline
by virtue we're all really oppressed by
that and the way to be truly free and
our authentic selves is to throw off all
of those shackles and all of those
limitations so we won't be limited by
the law we won't be limited by the moral
law we won't be limited by biology even
i won't even be limited by my
chromosomes we won't be limited by ages
age of consent statutes we won't be
limited by anything we're just going to
pursue our own
most disgusting appetites
whenever we want and then we're going to
be truly free
we know that's not
liberty the conservatives have a
different view of liberty which is that
the man who sins is a slave to sin and
you shouldn't groom the kids don't groom
the kids grooming the kids is not
liberty if your version of liberty
involves grooming the kids
you've gone down the wrong path you got
to come back you got to change your
your understanding
there's another question that's raised
by this video which is why are these
people not being arrested they should
all be arrested they should all be
thrown in prison and they should
probably throw away the key so why
aren't they
it's not because there aren't laws
against this there are laws against all
this stuff
it's just not prosecuted
there are laws against all this kind of
stuff
and it doesn't get prosecuted it's the
same reason it's the same reason that
blm gets to go kill and rape and kill
and pillage and burn and they basically
get a slap on the wrist and then the
horn hat guy cracks the coors light in
the capital rotunda and they they're
going to throw them in solitary and
throw away the key that's why it's not
because of the laws on the books it's
because of the ruling class that is
enforcing and not enforcing
those laws and frankly just enforcing
their own capricious will right now head
on over to rockauto.com write knowles in
their how did you hear about this box so
they know that we sent you
it is not going to come as any surprise
i'm not the handiest guy in the world
okay i'm not a total aficionado
connoisseur of car parts i know when
something breaks and the mechanic tells
me i need a part well then you got a
choice you can either go to the brick
and mortar auto parts store and it's
going to take a ton of your time and
you're going to get peppered with
questions you don't know the answer to
and then you're going to pay
50 more a hundred percent more sometimes
sometimes even more buddy of mine made a
mistake went to the brick and mortar
store they tried to charge him 400 for a
part where he thought huh wait what was
michael talking about the other day
pulls out his phone goes to rockauto.com
super easy catalog he pulls up the part
really quickly the part's 150 at rock
auto they wanted 400 at the brick and
mortar store don't do that prices are
always reliably low same prices for pros
and do-it-yourselfers super easy catalog
it's all at rockauto.com family business
serving auto parts customers online for
more than 20 years go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck then write knowles
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
you need to pay eight dollars a gallon
for gas to preserve the liberal world
order
refund please
um
if if what i am getting in exchange for
my eight dollars a gallon is the liberal
world order
i'm good thanks i'm good
i would like to no thank you
no
even if you discounted 20 off the
liberal world order no thanks there is
no amount of money i want to pay to
preserve because the liberal world order
is not working very well and i think
transgenderism in particular the drag
shows and the grooming and especially
transgenderism is really waking people
up to this fact there was a
a bulletin that came out of the toronto
police department over the weekend i did
not believe this was true
i looked it up it is true
said
toronto police
blue check mark verified account news
release missing woman ryerson avenue and
bat hurst street area isabella degrace
27 and then
and then you you look at a a picture of
this missing woman and it the guy looks
like joe dirt looks like it looks like
david spade in that movie he's got the
goatee kind of
reddish blonde goatee beard he's got a
man's haircut he's obviously a man i i
then i said this must be
the wrong post uh maybe the the social
media
person for the toronto police just
posted the wrong picture no because then
i looked at the news release
toronto police service requests public's
assistance locating a missing woman she
is described as five foot ten
with a thin build shaggy blonde hair and
a full goatee
it's not funny i feel bad for this guy
he's obviously a nut and and he went
missing
full goatee
the toronto police write
she was last seen wearing a black
t-shirt and gray pants
police are concerned about her safety
this is this is the kind of news release
that is sent out by the official
governing body of clown world
this is the the clown world police
department is releasing the headshot of
a dude with a goatee and saying that he
is a woman with a thin build
the transgender issue has become so
prominent one because of what we were
just talking about the libs the
liberation agenda
for from the libs
is
is constantly
accelerating so it's not just being
liberated from certain laws or being
liberated from certain traditional
social mores or being liberated from
certain institutions including the
family or being liberated from certain
symbols it's being liberated from
biology from human nature from
everything so that's why the libs are
pushing it in part
the trans agenda is really prominent for
the conservatives because it's waking us
up to the fact that we can no longer
trust our authorities
the liberal world order we can't trust
it
if the toronto police really believe
that shaggy goatee guy is a woman
then i can't trust the toronto police i
can't trust the toronto police or any
any
one of these similar institutions
i can't trust them on issues of sex
i can't trust them on anything
if you don't know that that dude is not
a chick
you
you don't know anything and so now i've
got to look out for myself
now i see no reason to support the
continued power and rule of these people
who don't know the most basic things
about human nature
i'm glad you like that clip now hold up
stop
whatever you're doing put it on pause
you've got to ring that bell get these
notifications i'm very close to a
million subscribers i assume at that
point youtube will just completely nuke
my channel and
all the shenanigans will seem like
nothing compared to the absolute nuclear
attack that they launch on my channel so
help me get to that point okay let's
accelerate everything here subscribe
ring that bell get the notifications
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you